money issues space fever and rip-offs
1978's Battlestar Galactica was battling
more than just bad ratings production
was chaotic and don't even get us
started on the cylons in 1978 the Sci-Fi
TV series Battlestar Galactica hit
television screens it seems like a
promising project at the time especially
in the wake of Star Wars fever and many
fans loved its epic narrative the story
revolves around the civilization of
humans living across 12 colonies who
believe that they are nearing the end of
a long war with the Cylon Empire they
soon discover however that they're
sorely mistaken in the wake of a
devastating attack a Dharma commander of
the last Starship standing forms a
ragtag army of Humanity's remaining
forces and heads out in search of the
13th colony Earth the show only lasted
one season before it was canceled and
critics today consider it to be one of
the biggest flops in TV history despite
inspiring a far more successful reboot
in the 2000s in 1979 The Washington Post
asked the show's writer Donald P
Bellisario by such a promising show
ended up on the chopping block he simply
said there are thousands of reasons in
the end though blamelay with the final
nail and so many television coffins
ratings Battlestar Galactica enjoyed
plenty of hype to begin with leading
mainstream media sources to declare the
show a hit the premiere which aired on
September 17 1978 was the fifth highest
program of its week however the Sci-Fi
show quickly lost ground to competition
on CBS which was airing shows like All
in the Family and NBC which set the
wonderful world of Disney in the time
slots against Battlestar Galactica the
rating slid downward rapidly from a 40
share to under 30 in less than two
months while the series still didn't do
badly overall to begin with it was
incredibly expensive Source has quoted
in the book by your command claimed that
the three-hour Pilot cost between 7
million and 14 million dollars to
produce each subsequent episode cost 1
million dollars which was more than
twice the average of an hour-long series
with ratings not meeting expectations
it's possible that ABC decided it didn't
need a massive cash-consuming sci-fi
project at the time Belisario told the
post I can't argue with numbers we have
dropped down there's no one thing to
blame Sunday night is the hottest
viewing night of the week and the other
networks hit us with everything they
could the show faced a few other
problems however
although his creator Glenn A Larson has
claimed that the concept for Battlestar
Galactica came from a pitch to Universal
Studios in 1967 by this time he was well
known for ripping off plots from movies
and many Saw major parallels between his
story about fighting an authoritative
regime and the plot of Star Wars which
had been released in 1977. in fact the
court case the 20th Century Fox brought
against Universal Studios MCA and ABC
cited 34 similarities between the two
projects while it's unclear if this
lawsuit had any true effect on the
prospects of the 1978 series it
certainly didn't help it's increased the
cost of the show while giving it heaps
of negative of birth and although the
suit wasn't settled until after the show
was canceled it's hard not to imagine
that it had a serious effect on its
reputation at the time a number of other
factors could have accounted for the
show's downfall for example some
accounts of the shows say that the
production was chaotic with scripts not
arriving until close to filming times
and the crew shooting on weekends just
to make deadlines by your command notes
that one sticking point between
producers and ABC took place around the
casting of character Starbuck as a
network would have preferred a different
actor than Dirk Benedict this conflict
likely spilled over into a production
issue on top of all that sci-fi in
general was the hardest sell in those
days as producer of the revamped
Battlestar Galactica one more pointed
out in a 2014 interview with Fast
Company the original series aired early
in the evening during a family-friendly
slot leading to some censoring of
elements that its creative team didn't
like Belisario complained that the evil
cylons became in his words rather
laughable and the show couldn't have
picked its killing machines as actual
menaces he'd sold the Washington Post we
just couldn't take them seriously we
just couldn't make them believable as
adversaries in the end while Battlestar
Galactica did improve successful in his
time it launched what grew to become a
landmark sci-fi franchise and for that
the original series deserves to be
remembered
[Music]